with companies tracking us across the
web we asked Tony to copal to see if
it's possible to shop online without
giving away any personal information
ethical here Tony the answer is yes and
way do you see how excited I was
actually pull this off our goal was to
buy something online benefiting from the
power of the internet but without
allowing any major tech company to track
the purchase back to us now there are a
few ways we could have done this but
with hidden trackers on most websites
and with companies making billions off
our information trying to hide is easier
said than done yeah thank you for your
order staples great work yep
if you're wondering why anyone would
high-five the purchase of a cat themed
office supply consider this I bought
mine online without it becoming part of
my online history my guide was kevin
Mitnick now you're best known as a
hacker well a security expert he spent
five years behind bars after stealing
information from major companies like
Motorola and Nokia and during a
nationwide manhunt in the mid-1990s he
eluded capture for more than two years
he now focuses on protecting corporate
security he shares tips for avoiding
surveillance in his book the art of
invisibility people want to protect
their privacy and people will go to the
trouble of anonymizing themselves to
protect their privacy
Mitnick says using privacy or incognito
mode on your computer browser is not
enough when you normally go on your
computer at your home or office you're
assigned an IP address by your internet
service provider and it's quite easy to
you know track that type of information
so what steps did we take to avoid being
tracked it started at the convenience
store what is step 1 well in an effort
to build our anonymous profile we're
gonna walk in and buy a prepaid gift
card why a gift card well it's an
anonymous credit card an anonymous
credit card we could use to shop online
what
step chew we bought a new computer one
not already associated with our regular
internet browsing step 3 we needed a way
to connect to the web we're gonna go
across the street and buy one now a hot
spot a hot spot in a mobile phone so
that way we could register for email
accounts like Gmail which might be
necessary to use this Chromebook
so we're buying a burner phone in order
to register for things on right and also
have a callback number because when you
do online shopping they always want to
have a phone number
open up the Chromebook step four we
connected our clean computer with a new
online identity I'll help you with us if
we signed in with our regular email
address it would be recognized by the
companies that track our data so we
created a new account since companies
can also identify us through our regular
internet connection we logged on using
the mobile hotspot we needed the phone
to verify our information and this is -
the prepaid phone well that's why we
have the prepaid after we invested about
four hundred dollars on equipment and
ten minutes setting up Add to Cart there
it is
companies had no way to associate our
real identities with what we were doing
online it's almost like a superpower a
cloak of invisibility right
exactly and that is a superpower but it
doesn't come free or easy or easy
basically you when you want more
security it's more inconvenient yeah and
speaking of inconvenient our address
could have connected us to the purchase
so we actually had to pick up our item
at the store and we did leave a digital
trail but remember it's only connected
to the fake online persona that we
created one mall one small mistake I'm
told like logging into our real email or
using our regular internet connection
and it would have allowed companies to
know exactly who went online shopping
for this little guy there ruin my online
and in addition to buying it anonymously
I can now write anonymous notes to all
of you
but that does seem like a lot of work
and a lot of expense to be in
visible online if you prioritize it it
will cost you there are other methods
like Tor and Bitcoin where arcane ways
but if you want to do it
straightforwardly with mainstream
products is the way you do it it felt
like you were trying to break the law
basically everything they are doing
illegal right we are advised like our
in-house Jason Bourne I am I like that a
lot
I don't know Bourne would buy this
though that's not going to stop your
cool factor just went down a couple of